[Music]
Nigeria's military rulers who seized
power last week have accused France of
planning an attack on the presidential
Palace to free to pose president
Muhammad bazoom France has condemned the
coup but has not announced any intention
to intervene militarily
the coup in Niger follows military
takeovers in neighboring Mali and
Burkina Faso in the past two years
they've been accompanied by a wave of
anger against the former colonial power
and the shift towards Russia
to intervene militarily in Niger France
with the complicity of certain Nigerians
held a meeting at the headquarters of
the National Guard of Niger to obtain
the necessary political and Military
authorizations for an attack
well that statement came after chance
president met the coup leaders to
negotiate a peaceful end to the
political crisis
the West African Regional block ecowas
is demanding the Junta reinstate the
deposed president in one week or face
the prospect of military action the coup
leaders have in turn warned their course
against any military intervention
Bernard Smith is standing by for us in
Paris first let's go to ahmedris his
life for us in Abuja so what details are
coming to life Ahmed about the
allegations of a French plan to
intervene militarily
exactly the accusation came from the
military authorities the spokesman the
main spokesman of the Junta in niamey he
alleged that there was a meeting at the
gods Brigade involving former ministers
and of course some elements within the
Army uh authorizing the French to take
action so as to attack the presidential
Palace and also Target certain Military
Officers in the country but that's the
body language that's the action that has
been seen in the action an utterances of
the coup since day one that has whipped
up already existing sentiments
anti-french sentiments in the year and
this one boiled over yesterday on Sunday
when we saw thousands of people out on
the streets demonstrating against France
asking for Russia to come in and also
some of them even broke away from the
larger crowd and attacked the French
Embassy in EMA Sammy and Ahmed what can
you tell us about reports of ministers
being arrested in a Crackdown
well there are reports of dozens of
arrests so far uh but eight prominent
members of the Belgium government or
cabinet or people are lying to him have
been arrested among them the most
prominent among them the minister of
petroleum resources and surprise
surprise sauna former uh president
muhammadu yusufu who is the Minister of
petroleum in that country I remember
Muhammad Yusuf appointed the current
military leader to head the presidential
guard himself and also recommended him
to the post-president Muhammad bazem to
retain him as presidential guard
Commander apart from him there are also
Ministers of Mines transportation
planning as well as the minister of
interior who was earlier on arrested
along with President Muhammad bazuma on
some top aides are in that cabinet also
on the arrest of course arrested today
is the president of the governing party
the PN de estaria as well as a former
Minister who is currently a member of
parliament in the current the form in
the large dispensation before the coup
Ahmed we've still got more to talk to
you about so stay with us for a second
but I know we've shifted gears a little
bit but let's come back to the issue of
those allegations of a French military
intervention plan and clearly the
European and France starting to show
they want to take action they say
they're going to cut off financial aid
to Niger the United States also
threatening to withdraw funding if
deposed president Muhammad bazoom is not
reinstated nearly 3.6 million people in
Nigeria are at risk of hunger more than
one million children are facing
malnutrition the nation receives close
to two billion dollars a year in
official development assistance the UN
says it's one of the least developed
countries in the world last year the EU
and France gave nearly 300 million
dollars in Aid the money supports
programs in emergency food assistance
and health
it's going to be disastrous for the
people because Niger is a country that
relies heavily on its partnership with
the International Community that provide
much support especially when it comes to
the second Financial year we secure a
budget for this time with financial aid
from the European Union the World Bank
and the IMF in particular along with the
French development agency turning once
back on this Aid is suicide
while to Serious Bernard Smith is live
for us in Paris so French officials have
spoken about aid but are they saying
anything about these allegations of
military intervention Bernard
some of the French Foreign Ministry has
said that it has no other objective than
the security of his citizens in Niger it
says our priority is the safety of our
Nationals and our property which cannot
be the object of violence the French
government has said that his Embassy was
on when came under sustained and violent
attack he says from people who were
clearly prepared and the security forces
Indonesia weren't able to contain them
and it says that it didn't use any
lethal force in protecting its Embassy
despite claims to the country from some
senior members of the Nigerian military
forces the European Union's also saying
that it will hold responsible all
attacks on civilians it will hold Niger
responsible for all attacks on civilians
diplomatic personnel and embassies there
is a lot of anti-french sentiment in its
former West African colonies and they've
now become a bit of a diplomatic ground
with or Battleground really on one side
we've got the French the Europeans and
on the other side you've got the
Russians and the Chinese all vying now
for influence in this part of West
Africa and you can see that's one of the
reasons why the Europeans particularly
the French are so interested and
concerned about what's happening there
at the moment Sammy
thanks so much Bernard Smith let's go
back to Ahmed Idris he has been
monitoring as I said everything that's
happening from Abuja and Ahmed
you know Bernie was talking about the
Diplomatic tensions there where is the
proposal from the president of Chad
going is it getting any traction to try
and resolve this peacefully
we understand that President Idris Derby
has left Niger already after a meeting a
Nigerian leader president bolatinibu
along with other West African leaders in
Abuja ahead of the summit yes on Sunday
he took the demands of ecowas and of
course a proposal to the military rulers
in cha in Niger and he was able to meet
with the military High command including
of course the military ruler the
self-appointed leader of Nigeria now he
met also president Mohamed bazum former
president Muhammad yusufu and some
senior officials of the government there
they didn't say exactly what was inside
the proposal and whether or not the
authorities India have accepted them but
we understand that he spent hours
discussing this with all parties
concerned and he has left Indonesia at
the moment he is due to brief and
probably by now as we talk or as we
speak he must be briefing the president
of Nigeria who is the current chairman
of the economic community of West
African States now failure to adhere to
the demands of ecowas we understand that
the echo's heads of states and
government have ordered military to be
on standby for possible intervention in
Asia the military High commands in all
the countries that are going to
participate have met and are continue to
discuss the modalities of that in case
the leaders authorize the use of force
there however there are signs that
things may be throwing a little bit
Indonesia at the moment there are rumors
but they're not confirmed possibly in
the next few days probably by weekend we
may see the lifting of sanctions I mean
the lifting of closure of borders but
that is not confirmed yet that's what
we're hearing for the moment but it's
not official
all right thanks so much Ahmed Idris
well Christopher for Munoz from the
national Democratic Institute for
international Affairs he's the regional
director for Central and West Africa
programs at the American NGO joins us
now live from Washington DC good to have
you with us so first of all let's start
with these suggestions or allegations of
a French military operation How likely
is that
well thanks uh Sami for having me um I
would I mean if this was not a serious
question I would just laugh it away
because no country that's credible uh
that's uh experience would go hold a
meeting in the capital city of a country
being controlled by a junta to discuss
how to take military action so I'll just
you know it's true that the French Have
Become this trauma in in in this Sahel
but I wouldn't put a lot of stock on the
alleged meeting
we also know that sanctions are mounting
up on Niger
the EU France possibly it's been
suggested the US will be next how is
that going to impact the economic
situation of the country
oh I mean this sanctions are for real
and the Nigerian prime minister
yesterday underscore the fact that Niger
is a country that depends
tremendously on foreign assistance and
will not be able to find its path its
pathway uh without such assistance I
think the sanctions from ecowas are real
they're strong they're firm ecowas has
demonstrated its desire to draw the line
in the sun with regards to the bunta and
Niger and I think that the other
sanctions that are likely to come from
the African Union the global system and
and developing Partners will really have
a negative impact on the population of
Niger and I think that's really the
wake-up call for the current winter to
say that if if they really have the
intentions and the interests of their
people at had then they're going to have
to pull back from this foolishness and
from dragging the 27 million people of
Malaysia into inspirational Collective
suicide
and also if we can talk a little bit
about what that means when we're seeing
a lot of strain in relations between the
formal colonial power between Western
countries and niger's current rulers
does that give an opening for Russia
well I you know some people would
immediately see the fact that uh a few
Russian flags were waived at the pro
hunter demonstration yesterday uh as a
sign that that may provide an opening
for Russia uh but I would hesitant to
add that uh even this morning we had a
krembling saying they would want to see
a return to legality in Niger and
secondly that there are nuances with
what's happening not just in Asia but
across most of francophone Africa that's
certainly an anti-fringe sentiment
especially among young Africans and
sometimes justifiably so but that does
not immediately translate into a
full-scale Embrace of Russia and I think
that means doesn't need doesn't have to
be lost
all right we'll leave it there for now
thanks so much
thank you for having me